[موسيقى]
في الواقع لقد كان اداء الاقتصاد الروسي
افضل بكثير مما كان متوقعا في 2022
فاجمالي الناتج القومي تقلص لكن بنسبه
اثنين واثنين من عشره فقط وفقا لصندوق
النقد الدولي لان التبعات الاقتصاديه
للغزو والعقوبات الناتجه عن ذلك قابله
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه والاحتياطيات القويه
لدى روسيا ما دعم الاقتصاد الروسي
[موسيقى]
وقد كان متوقعا ان يشهد الاقتصاد الروسي
تراجعا اكبر من هذا فقد كان اكثر من عشره
في المئه في وقت سابق من عام 2022 عندما
انهار الروبل امام الدولار حتى في اكتوبر
كانت توقعات صندوق النقد الدولي ان يكون
التقلص الاقتصادي الروسي ثلاثه واربعه من
عشره في المئه وتحسن الارقام لتصل الى
اثنين واثنين من عشره حسب البيانات
الاخيره هو دليل على ان الاداء الاقتصادي
في روسيا افضل بكثير مما كان متوقعا به
[موسيقى]
اولهما ان التكنوقراط الروس اداروا هذه
الازمه بشكل جيد باستخدام التكتيك اتبعوه
منذ العقوبات التي فرضت على روسيا في عقرب
ضمها للقرم اما السبب الثاني فهو ان
العقوبات على الطاقه من الغرب لم تفرض
بشكل حاسم حتى ديسمبر 2022 وبالتالي اثرها
كان ضعيفا
[موسيقى]